[Music]
20:18 saw the emergence of the first
hundred billion dollar man the idea of
that much money is enough to make your
head spin but don't tell me you've never
dreamed about it the question is what
would you do what could you do
would you buy the crown jewels a giant
house or a private plane would you make
the world a better place could you even
live long enough to spend it this is
what if and here's what you could buy
with a hundred billion dollars it seems
like those with money are often judged
by how they use it some people spend
more than the cost of a college
education on a car and then there are
campaigns like The Giving Pledge that
has seen 175 of the world's wealthiest
people pledging to donate the majority
their fortunes to charitable causes so
far the members of The Giving Pledge
have collectively promised more than
three hundred and sixty five billion
dollars but for a lot of us it's hard to
quantify that type of money so to help
put it all in perspective here are some
of the things you could buy with a
hundred billion dollars you've been
thinking about that dream vacation for a
while and now you can finally go
wherever you want for as long as you
want but what does it mean to travel in
style well for a hundred billion dollars
you could buy around two hundred and
fifty Boeing 747s in other words
establish your own private airline but
if you're seriously considering a kingly
existence why not buy an entire country
with a GDP of ninety billion dollars you
could practically own Costa Rica and
while you're busy turning the world into
a Monopoly board why not add another
game to your collection with a hundred
billion dollars you could furnish a real
version of the classic board game
with the cost of two small fleets each
with its own aircraft carrier coming in
at about fifty billion dollars it's up
to you how much you want to spend on
fuel ammo and personnel with just half
of your fortune you could buy the
world's largest royal domain the Palace
of Versailles with its 700 rooms 600
paintings 400 sculptures and 1,400
fountains in fact you'd still have
enough left over for the White House
Buckingham Palace st. Petersburg's
Winter Palace and Tokyo's Imperial
Palace or you could just buy the Louvre
in its contents for a modest forty five
billion but if art isn't your thing how
about sports with the average cost of an
American football franchise at 1 billion
dollars you could own every team in the
National Football League and still have
enough left over to buy all the teams in
Major League Baseball the National
Hockey League and the English Premier
League while you might call that a
win-win it's important to remember that
for some people a billion in the bank is
not just a reality but a serious
responsibility 100 billion dollars is
enough money to put roughly seven
hundred and fifty seven thousand
students through American colleges for
four years you could triple America's
proposed foreign assistance budget for
2019 offering three times the amount of
food medicine and security to a wider
range of recipients in over 100
countries considering that it would only
cost an estimated sixty million dollars
to save the Great Barrier Reef think how
far one hundred billion dollars could
take us along the path of sustainable
living and environmental protection of
course we could always diversify and
tackle several world issues at once a
team of some of the world's top
economists claim that an annual
investment of three billion dollars
could reduce malnutrition in the
developing world by 36% saving over 100
million children from starvation each
year on top of that an additional two
billion dollars every year towards
agricultural research and development
would not only increase global food
security but also protect biodiversity
and prevent deforestation these are
trends that could only become more
cost-effective as they continue to be
funded it may seem like a sad reality to
consider
that money really does make the world go
round but that doesn't mean we have to
think selfishly put towards a good cause
money can make a world of difference
lifting people out of poverty and
stimulating growth education and
innovation as long as enough people
remain willing to give back then we
should all consider ourselves fortunate
so how about it what would you do with a
hundred billion dollars
[Music]
you